le pavot
à deux pas du périphérique tourangeau le
val de choisir un espace naturel
sensible qui abrite une grande
biodiversité et au milieu de cette
nature préservée énigmatique et
surprenant un monolithe de 8 m 22 ans le
carbone shelter un geste à la fois
artistique et écologique
je voulais justement une oeuvre assez
forte et radicale déjà de prime abord
qui surprennent qui choque qui soit un
objet qui détonne vraiment avec le
paysage en même temps qui va se
dissimuler dès que la nuit va tomber qui
va devenir vraiment un espace de refuge
mais je l'avais envisagé comme une
peinture monochrome un bleu un bloc
uniforme qui est cette vraie cette vraie
force plastique en fait les gîtes qui
sont les plus fins avec une planche qui
est strié ça c'est vraiment pour les
chiroptères donc l'estrie ça leur permet
ça laissait pour les aider en fait à
grimper à l'intérieur elles viennent se
glisser en famille ou en colonie
après peuvent voilà nidifier après fond
à fond leur vie de chauves souris les
formes un peu plus longue pour les
martinez avec des trous de 3 cm par 7 cm
donc la cd martinoire en l'occurrence
après à certaines boîtes qui sont
purement esthétique et graphique
ce que je voulais que cette pièce existe
plastiquement hirondelles de fenêtre ou
rustiques martinez chauve-souris la
sculpture refuge de françois xavier
chanioux a dû répondre à des contraintes
environnementales et scientifiques
le plasticien travailler avec des
ornithologues et chiroptérologue pour
construire nichoirs et refuge forcément
en bois la taille fallait face à face au
minimum cinq mètres voire six mètres
pour les martinez qui ne seraient jamais
venus sinon l'acier au départ qui aurait
été pratique il y avait des contraintes
thermiques qui était trop importante
donc ça aurait été trop chaud l'été est
beaucoup trop froid l'hiver tous les
produits à base de pétrole donc les
résines polyester époxy tout ça il
fallait proscrire les gîtes sont
orientés nord-est
parce que s'il était en plein soleil ça
marcherait pas françois xavier chanioux
est déjà dessinée imaginer le futur du
carbone shelter investi par les chauves
souris et les oiseaux une sculpture
monumentale au service de la
biodiversité des 150 hectares du val de
choisir entre saint cyr sur loire et
fondettes